[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: Welcome
back to 8.701.
We are starting a new
chapter on instrumentation.
And in this first section,
we'll discuss the interaction
of particles with matter.
So what happens when
particles traverse
through a piece of material?
The underlying
principle of detection
is that we do have to have
some sort of interaction
of the material of the detector
with the particles going
through.
And there needs to be some
sort of transfer of energy
which can be identified.
Then, that piece
of energy can be
amplified, separated
from noise, and so on.
But this first part of
any detection process
is this interaction of
this particle with matter.
We can ask, what
kind of particles
can we actually identify?
Electrons, muons, pions, kaons,
protons, neutrons, heavy ions,
and photons.
But the key here in
this list of particles
is that those particles
have to be stable.
So we cannot directly
identify tau,
as the tau decays before it
has a chance to interact with
the detector.
The same for our top quark,
the Higgs boson, and so on.
Interesting, neutrinos.
Neutrinos interact with the
detector very, very rarely.
When they do, they
actually detect a signal
that is not of the neutrino
directly, but of the products
of the interaction.
So we will split
this discussion up
in the interaction
of neutral particles
and charged particles, and
we start with the photon.
So the photon interacts
with detector material.
With material in general, we
have three leading effects.
The photo effect,
Compton scattering,
and pair production.
In the photo effect,
we have a photon
interacting with an atom, and
then kicking out an electron.
And then, your
detector has a chance
to identify the energy and
the momentum of the electron.
This concept is used in
photo multiplier tubes
where then the kicked out
electron is further amplified.
And that leads to a
shower of electrons
which can be measured like
the photodiode [? species ?]
effect.
We have discussed the
Compton effect quite a bit.
Here, the energy of
the scattered electron
can be measured out of the
energy of the scattered photon.
And then there's
pair production.
Pair production
dominated high energies.
And typically, it's
part of an initiation
process of electromagnetic
showers in calorimeters.
That's great.
So what happens in
the calorimeter--
and we'll talk about
this more later--
is that an incoming photon or
electron causes this photon
to convert into pairs of
electrons and positrons.
And then there's this cascade
of electrons and positrons,
and additional photons
being produced.
In tracking detectors,
this is unwanted.
So therefore, build tracking
detectors rather thin.
We don't want to
have this confusion
of additional charged
particles, and we
try to measure the
energy of a proton.
So this plot here shows you
the cross-section as a function
of the photon energy.
And you see here very
nicely those three effects
contributing to the
total cross-section.
So for low energies--
in the range of some 100 keV,
the photo effect dominates.
And there is this intermediate
range from about 100 keV
to about 10 MeV where we see the
effect of Compton scattering.
And everything above this is
dominated by pair production.
And this here shows
you that there
are some differences in what
kind of material you interact,
of course.
Photon or electron interaction.
Again, the main
energy loss mechanism
for high energy photons
and electrons in matter
is through pair production,
and also bremsstrahlung.
Bremsstrahlung is the effect
when an electron or positron
radiates a photon.
You can characterize
the materials
by introducing a concept
of radiation length.
And there's some
confusion sometimes.
In the definition,
they are very similar,
but they're not quite the same.
Radiation length can be defined
as the length after which
an electron loses about
1 over e of its energy
by bremsstrahlung.
And you often find
the definition
through the mean
free path lengths.
And in X0, the
radiation length is
defined as 7/9 of the mean free
path length for pair production
by a photon.
So those are the
two definitions.
And they're typically
used in the regime
where the process is dominant.
It's a very convenient
property because of quantity,
because you don't have to worry
about when you're thinking
about the interaction
of the detector,
about the specific thickness
and what it means in terms
of energy loss, and simply
know that your piece of lead
is a fraction of a
radiation length.
And that tells you how
many of your photons
or how much of the photon
energy is being lost.
Typically, when you
build detector concepts
like a collider experiment
like ATLAS or CMS,
you want the tracking volume
to be of low radiation length.
And for ATLAS and
CMS, this depends
on the rapidity or
the forward direction,
but it varies between 30% and
200% of the radiation length.
And for calorimeters, you
want that all the energy is
deposited in the calorimeter.
Nothing has leaked
out in the back,
and therefore, you design
calorimeters typically
with 20 or 30 radiation
lengths [INAUDIBLE]..
So again, when me think about
how a photon or an electron
leaves a footprint
in a calorimeter,
you start from this first
electron and photon.
And then, this particle evolves
in an electromagnetic shower.
So there's this cascade
effect as the particle tries
to move through this material.
The shower maximum
is given here.
Slightly depends on the energy.
It uses logarithmic dependency.
I introduce here the
critical energies.
This is where the energy
loss through ionization
is equal to the bremsstrahlung.
And you see this
in this plot here--
It's rather small--
as a function
of energy and the energy loss.
Again, you see, this effect
here is from ionization.
And this effect here
is from bremsstrahlung.
The critical energy is defined
as where those two energy loss
mechanisms give you
the same result.
So this is just a
normalization factor.
But you see that there is
this logarithmic dependency
of the energy loss.
You can also wonder how wide
a shower actually becomes.
And this is given by the width.
The transverse
width of the shower
is given by the Moliere radius.
And that's approximate.
You find 21 MeV over
the critical energy
times the radiation
length gives you
the size of the transverse
sides of your shower.
And in this example,
this is 8 centimeters,
compared to a shower
length of 46 centimeters.
This is a very quick summary
of electromagnetic showers.
You can also have nuclear
showers, of course.
You have a neutron or a proton
entering your calorimeter.
Here, the physics is a
little bit more complicated,
but you can introduce
similar concepts.
This concept of radiation
lengths for strong interactions
of the hadron with the nuclei.
So as for the
electromagnetic shower,
there is this
cascade developing.
However, if in the
cascade, for example,
you would choose a neutron.
That neutron can travel
without leaving an interaction
for quite a distance.
So you don't have
this continuous kind
of flow of energy, and you have
little clusters of energies.
And in those clusters, you have
not just nuclear interaction,
but you can also
produce new pions.
And those new pions decay
into a pair of photons.
And then, the photons, they
leave electromagnetic showers.
So hadronic showers have
typically two components--
a hadronic part, which is
charged hadrons, pions, kaons,
protons, neutrons, and an
electromagnetic part which
is [INAUDIBLE] coming from
the decay of the neutrons.
From the decay of the neutral
pions, which are photons.
So here, just to give you a
feel four orders of magnitude,
radiation length given--
the nuclear and the
electromagnetic radiation
is given as a function
of Z. And for a gas,
we're talking about
hundreds of meters.
For light material--
aluminum and silicon--
we talk about 10 centimeters.
And for heavy
material-- specifically
lead-- we're talking about
sub-centimeter radiation
length.
Moving from the neutral
particles from the photons
and electrons--
sorry-- to the charged
particle interactions.
Here again, just summarizing
or giving a summary first,
and then going through
the individual components.
The interaction mechanisms
are multiple scattering--
elastic scattering
with the atoms.
This is a process
which is not very
much wanted because,
when you try
to monitor the trajectory
of the particle,
you don't want it to
scatter and change randomly
its direction or momentum.
Ionization is a basic mechanism
for tracking detectors.
Photon radiation is
an important part
through bremsstrahlung but
also through Cerenkov radiation
or transition radiation.
And then, in scintillators,
you can excite the material.
And then, if you have a
wavelength shifting fiber
material, you can cause
scintillation light
to be shifted in wavelength.
And then you can read
this out in order
to gain information about
particles going through.
All right.
Let's start with
multiple scattering.
So after passing a layer
of thickness with L,
a particle with
some displacement r
and some angle of deflection.
So that is problematic
because you lose information
through the random process.
You see here this random
Gaussian-like distribution
which is rather annoying.
So the key here is to
minimize the radiation lengths
of the particle going through.
The next part is an ionization.
Again, this is a primary
source of information
we gained from in
tracking detectors.
Typically, you have a number
of primary interactions
per unit length which
are Poisson distribution.
So it's a random
process whether or not
the particle sees an
atom which it can ionize.
And typically, in a
gas, you find about 30
of those primary
interactions per centimeter.
You have more in
denser materials.
If you have kicked out an
electron in your ionization
process, that electron
itself can again
lead to secondary ionization.
And once those electrons
reach sufficient energy,
they're sometimes visible as
individual tracks themselves.
They called delta electrons--
new particles which are visible
in your tracking detector.
Energy fluctuations can
be really, really large
through ionization.
Sometimes, you have a
really tough interaction
and you transfer a lot of
energy to the electron,
while the mean number
is well under control.
So, interesting.
Just to give you
a feel, again, you
have about 30
primary interactions
per centimeters in gas.
The total ionization
energy you find
is typically 3 times the
primary ionization energy.
So you cause those seeds of
ionization, and then the energy
to move away from
this initial track.
When you look at the
energy loss distribution,
this is a nice plot here
I made many, many years
ago of the energy loss
in a piece of silicon
of 100 gb pion.
So this pion loses its energy
primarily through ionization.
And this is a small piece of
silicon which we used here.
So you see this
typical distribution.
It's called the
Landau distribution
with a most probable value
and then a very long tail.
And this tail here is dominated
by those delta electrons
I was talking about.
In bubble chamber or
cloud chamber pictures,
you see those delta
electrons here
as little curls of ionization
along the main part
of your particle leading
an ionization track.
The energy loss of
charged particles
can be calculated using
the Bethe-Bloch formula.
And it's a very good
description in a specific energy
range-- in the
energy range which
is dominated by ionization.
And so, the formula
is given here.
We discuss this some more
in our recitation section.
But you see here in this
medium energy range,
you are dominated with
Bethe-Bloch formula
or by ionization where, when you
go into higher energies here,
you find additional
energy loss--
energy loss with radiation.
So we can study the details
of this Bethe-Bloch formula.
One interesting point is
the particle dependency
of the energy loss-- and you
see this here shown for a muon,
for a pion, and for proton.
If you measure the energy
loss of a specific particle
in a reasonable
momentum range, you
can use that
information in order
to learn which particle
travels through your detector.
So you can use energy loss
in some cases in combination
with the momentum measurement
in order to identify particles.
Last but not least,
more radiation effects.
Cerenkov radiation is
a very neat feature
to also measure
particles as they
go through a specific material.
They can also be used in order
to identify particles again.
So the idea here is
that Cerenkov radiation
is emitted when
a particle passes
through a dielectric medium with
a speed larger than the speed
of the light in that medium.
And that causes
a radiation cone.
It's like a sonic boom when
you have airplanes passing by.
And the simple picture is one
of the classical pictures.
It's one of this wave front
cone under a specific Cerenkov
angle.
And then, last but not
least, transition radiation.
This is a process which
were predicted by Ginzburg
and Frenck in the 1940s.
His idea is that a
photon is emitted
when a charged particle
transfers through the boundary
of two mediums.
And so, if you
have a medium here
in a vacuum, for example, if the
particle travels through here,
it polarizes the
medium when it exits.
And that polarization then
leads to an electric dipole
which then starts to radiate.
And you get a photon from
this type of radiation.
So if you measure this
type of radiation,
you might be able to identify
that the particle traveling
through the transition of two
materials was an electron.
All right.
So this is the first
introduction to the topic.
So in the next part, we
now have to understand
how we use those phenomena
in order to build detectors.